Veronica Hatterline Hattberg.
Um, Veronica is a senior researcher in
uh semantics and reasoning at uh Siemens
Foundational Technologies.
Um, she's been in the field of knowledge
modeling with uh many years of
experience
uh across a range of industries from
offshore, defense, public sector, and
manufacturing.
Um, given her in-depth insights into how
to bring the the best of different of
these different communities of practice
together.
Uh,
and and you could probably say that uh
in terms of her uh academic background,
she uh comes from a uh linguistics
background.
Um, currently in her work in Siemens uh
research and pre-development. Uh,
and over the years uh she's been
involved in in a variety of different
communities of practice uh both in
Norway and in Germany.
And uh
I'll I'll leave further to to you to
talk, but the the her talk today is a
polyglot domain model library, narrowing
the gap between semantic engineers,
domain and standardization experts, and
software developers.
Um, I look forward.
Please join me in welcoming Veronica.
Thank you. Thank
>> [applause]
>> Can you hear me okay? Oh, yeah,
wonderful.
Um, yeah, and um as Paco said, I'm a
linguist and in my day-to-day work
I um help um our business units um
mechanical engineers, electrical
engineers, process engineers model their
domain knowledge into our data structure
so that the software actually reflects
the
knowledge. So, this talk will be very
much a report from the ground how it is
to be semantic modeling in our
organization.
What will I be talking about? First, I
will very briefly introduce what Siemens
Siemens does and why we need semantics
because we don't produce washing
machines anymore,
which is what most people associate with
Siemens. Um and what we tried in a first
attempt in order to introduce semantics
um and where we struggled and what how
we now think that we need to proceed
from from this onwards to what something
we call the polyglot domain model
library.
Okay, so what do we do? Um very very
simply put, and my colleagues will
shake their heads now when they hear
this but
we
uh we produce hardware to steer other
hardware, right? We produce these small
or big computers which can steer robots,
mixers, milling machines, assembly
lines, entire factories, right? Um
we built um
control um devices for energy flow in
buildings, grid grid um management, etc.
But increasingly over the last 15 years,
we have turned into more of a software
house, so we build a lot of software and
digital twins in order to help our
customers to steer these devices even
better, to learn from the data um which
these devices produce, um
yeah, and to improve their own
processes.
Um so we like to say that we connect the
physical with the digital world.
That's somehow the baseline.
And that's where the beauty is, but also
the challenge as we just will see.
Since we are dealing with a domain or
several domains which have been formally
described for
decades, even if not even centuries, at
least many many years before we had
large-scale software development and
data integration, um we not only have to
deal with
heterogeneity on the consistency level,
we also have to live with a what we call
in German historically grown forest of
standards and norms and and um
ways of expressing um
domain knowledge.
We have a wide range of meta models to
handle exchange formats
domain descriptions, right? So,
it's really a mess up there.
Um
so when we talk about building knowledge
graphs, our actual challenge is not
the consistency level here.
It's the big question of how to get to
the shared knowledge layer.
And the entire talk will actually be
about how to get there, right? And what
we have tried and what we think we need
to do now.
Some four or five years ago,
we um built something and and open up
something which we call the Siemens
ontology library,
which is a a Siemens-wide or
organization-wide um portal where you
can
access um
highly curated ontologies which which we
built ourselves,
but also recommendations for for
external ontologies which we recommend
to reuse like the industrial data on
ontology or the QUDT
ontology.
Um
we equipped this portal with guidelines
and templates um for uploading or
creating your own ontology and uploading
it it. And we recommended our business
units to whenever they do data modeling,
they should look into the ontology
library and see if there's anything they
can reuse, right?
On the other side, we also recommended
very strongly to them that whenever they
are finished with their data modeling
project, they should publish the data
model as an ontology and submit it to
our portal so that other business units
can see it and reuse it.
What we also said without really wanting
to say this is that if your domain is
not described in our RDF, it does not
exist. It means it's not visible for the
rest of the organization, right?
And this is part of the problem we now
see we need to address.
Now I would like to take you a little
bit into my day-to-day life with my
colleagues. Um
this is from a project with my
colleagues from the mechanical
engineering department.
They were tasked with coming up with a
target schema for our data not our own
own data scientists, but even for our
customer data scientists for onboarding
so-called assembly tools. Those are
tools where you have a shaft and you can
switch whether it should hold a drill, a
cutter, um a screwdriver, right? Um
And these tools are standardized and
they are described in DIN or ISO or IEC
or not not IEC in this case, but in in
DIN and ISO norms.
And in this special special case, um
the knowledge of these two around these
two the properties in order to get them,
you need to go to at least two different
norms. And within these two norms, you
have to access uh four different places.
So first of all,
the tools um are classified by pictures.
So this is a picture of a milling cutter
with where you already can know you need
to describe it along um
its dimensions.
Um but then you need to go to another
place in the same norm to retrieve all
the properties which cannot be displayed
in a picture, but which you also have to
have in your data structure, right? Then
you need to go to another table where
you need to find out whether this
property is mandatory or optional, and
then
you yet another place where you get a
pattern for describing this one uh
property. In this case, it's balancing
quality, the way something rotates, if
it rotates. Okay.
So at
at this point, once you have this
everything uh in this um data structure,
which uh is just happens to be a data
structure in this case,
you are all sweat and tears, right? You
have Your team is really
done with it. So, creating an ontology
on top of this is just an OWL ontology
in in in language which is not familiar
to any engineer, right? It's just just
something you don't have on your
priority list.
Um
So, last year we sat down and and
really thought hard about our first um
attempt to to uh introduce semantics in
a more structured way.
And we needed to honestly admit that
the two main goals we had with this
weren't really achieved, right?
The creation and cu- curation of
ontologies didn't really happen except
outside a small group of ontology enthu-
enthusiasts, OWL enthusiasts, I need to
say.
Partly because the
the tooling is not intuitive for
engineers. They don't think in tabs for
classes, object properties, data
properties. They think in spatial
diagrams, right? They It's a totally
different way of thinking around things.
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> And also, when we, the ontologists, sit
down with our um domain experts and
model their knowledge, it doesn't simply
doesn't scale because it takes 5 years
to become an electrical engineer. How
can I, as an ontologist, grasp this
knowledge in in the course of 3 months,
right? So, it doesn't scale.
Um
and also we we simply ideally we would
like to have colleagues who can both a
domain in every depth and express it in
in all, but
those people are very rare to be found.
I actually have only two colleagues
among 30 in my group.
Um and on the other hand um the code the
software code which is produced is still
not really directly informed by the
ontologies we we have, right? Even
though we we really encourage everyone.
Um this is somehow a culture clash
because our software architects are very
into
microservices, domain driven design, and
they independency, right? They want to
the service to be to run independently.
They don't want to coordinate with every
anyone else, right?
Um
and also they find find it a cognitive
burden to go and and look through an
ontology right?
So, we end up with islands of
semantically annotated services, but
they are not not connected with each
other. So, each time we want to create
set up a new knowledge graph, we have
this really extensive need of semantic
mapping.
So, what we did then was we
said we need to go and ask them what
what do you need in order to make
semantic annotation of your data
structures happen, right? What How how
can we help you to make this easy for
you?
And
we gathered four learnings from these
interviews,
which then informed um
the requirements for our um
new approach.
Um
those are except that domain models come
in all shapes and sizes. Um we need to
accept that truth is both global,
meaning in an ontology, but also local
in the
individual service.
Um we need to focus on transparency
first before we even can think of
harmonizing
vocabularies right?
And then last but no perhaps most
importantly
understanding a domain model is
basically a hectic process. You can't
just throw a documentation of an
ontology over the fence and then expect
others to understand it even
especially if they're not into OWL,
right?
So what do we mean by this?
The first learning, accept that domain
models come in all shapes and sizes.
We as
my entire team, we are ontologists,
right? OWL fans.
And we live in this Protégé picture,
right? So for us the world consists of
Protégé. But the reality is that most of
the domain descriptions actually do not
exist in OWL, right? They exist in loads
and loads of norms and standards from
ISO IEC, um
you name it and
and that's in the in the application
independent um range and then the
application specific range we we find
domain descriptions in the payloads of
APIs. We find them in enterprise
architect projects. We even find them in
Python scripts, right? When we have data
scientists who
who don't have know how to model
uh any domain or write a vocabulary
um other than in in putting them into
their Python scripts.
So we needed to acknowledge that that
domain descriptions there's a whole
range of domain descriptions we have
ignored until now.
So our new attempt, the first
requirement for the new attempt is it
needs to be formalism agnostic. That
means it needs to be able to show and
make accessible data structures and
domain descriptions
which are other than our right.
That's the first one.
Um
Second learning, the truth is both
global and local.
That refers to the fact that we as
ontologist we we like to think that an
ontology covers
the entire this is the truth about the
domain, right? And everything else is
not just really not true because it's
just
not large enough.
But when you for instance this is an
excerpt for excerpt from a building
ontology brick.
Um
but if you um
if you have
an engineer factory engineer planning
engineer and plan your factory setup,
right? You have a factory with a
production area, assembly lines and
workstations. For you you for instance a
room is only interesting by way of its
identifier because it indicates for you
where the production area
how where it cross um stretches, right?
So this is a legitimate representation
of the truth about rooms that in this
context it's actually only interesting
in by way of its identifier.
When you're facility manager and want to
describe your your
your building in terms of what it can
offer as services, then of all of a
sudden it's important to know about the
room what kind kind of capabilities it
has whether you can use it as a wet
storage or
uh especially clean room or or all kinds
of capabilities, right? But you're not
so much interested in anything else or
about reasoning about this room, right?
You just want the this one um
part of it.
So we need to accept that these are
truths in their own right because that's
the only thing that's relevant in this
specific context.
Um so when we build this new um library,
we need to be able to support uh the
user
that he or she can look at the concept
of room and and and see all the
perspectives perspectives in which the
um it it's used, right? So, that you can
get a 360° um
view on on the use of use of room.
That's the second requirement.
Um
The third learning is that right now,
and this is a very pragmatic
learning, right now we simply have to
focus on transparency and not so much
about coordination and harmonization of
vocabularies
for the simple reason that we
you can't harmonize anything which you
cannot see, right? You need to make it
visible first. Um
So,
in this first iteration, we we will
focus on on on making these um domain
models, regardless of formalism,
findable and accessible.
And we also want them to make them
reusable in in terms of that we want to
make them translatable from one
formalism, like OPC UA, which is an
important formalism for us, to asset
administration shell, which is another
formalism right?
So, so that our service developers can
reuse the same um
domain description but in in a different
formalism, depending on the the use
case.
Um and only then can we think of uh
coordination and interoperability,
really true uh semantic
interoperability. And that's where OWL
again becomes important. We need to um
then take the step up to to OWL and and
um
start trying to harmonize. How we will
do this, and this is also about change
propagation down into the instance
level, is still very much unclear. This
is very fresh off uh off the press,
somehow. Um but we know that this is
somehow the direction or the sequence we
want to go into.
So, our third requirement for the new
approach is that we want to build a fair
domain model library with the eye for
the interoperability somehow in bracket
still because we
we can't
bite over everything at at the same
time right?
And then the fourth learning
understanding a domain model is a hectic
process. I often think when I think of
about this about my 13-year-old son, I
can create like the most beautiful
system for sorting his school books. He
will not understand and adopt it if he
doesn't really interact with it, right?
If I keep on doing it for him, it will
not become his system, right? So, you
need one needs to have an hectic
interaction with the with the
these domain models.
Very practical speaking, that means no
one ever from our domain experts or our
service developers approaches us and and
says, "Tell me something about about the
brick ontology, right? Or about the
sensor and ontology." Nobody reads
ontologies because it's fun.
Yeah,
except for perhaps our experts.
Um
So, they come to me with or to my
colleagues with a very um specific
question like, "I need to specify a REST
API for sensor health. And I've heard
that the sensor
ontology is really good for describing
sensors. How how can I build a payload
for this based on this um ontology?" And
until now we have left them to their own
devices and said, "Yeah, here is the
sensor ontology, go figure." Um and that
that doesn't suffice, right? They have a
lot of time pressure, so we need to
give them more actionable um
options for that.
So, our fourth requirement actually for
the solution we are trying to hand for
is
that domain models need to be
actionable. You need to be able to
download you you
at [clears throat] first suggestion for
an payload for your API from a bricks
ontology. You need to be able to have
your
data structures and
assembly tools translated in into an
asset administration shell format and
these kinds of things, right? That's
where our
service developers are, right? So, we
need to really meet them at the
everyday
work.
So, given all these four learnings, um
we have developed a very first target
picture.
Um I must admit that this is
the thought work of my colleague
colleague Thomas Hubauer who couldn't
join today. He's like the technical
mastermind and the
leading architect behind.
Um and you don't need to understand
every detail. I I just want to point out
three takeaways for you.
Um where we earlier only had this owl
cycle repository to show show domain
models, we now want to make visible um
domain models in in in many other
formalisms which are important to us. I
don't know if they are surely not
important to others, but for us OPC UA
and and AS for instance automation ML
are industry standards um
formalisms which we simply need to be
able to support, right? Um so, we want
to open up our um
repository of of domain models to cover
these um
formalisms.
The second takeaway is that we
for the data contract, we we make this
distinction between data contracts and
our ontologies in the in the term that
data contracts are application specific.
They are
closed world in a way. They they tell
you what you can expect when you when
you
request a certain um set of data.
Um
And for that, we have created an
internal neutral model from formalism
like it type um type um data type uh
formalism where we want to be able to um
you come with an OPC UA model and you
can um have it translated into this
neutral model as long as it it you you
speak OPC UA, we will always be able to
support you in expressing this in in
asset administration shell through by
means of this neutral um model model
layer.
Obviously, not everything can be
translated lossless. So, we also have
this auxiliary file store so that we
always can also roll back. So, when you
come from an open world uh
ontology our ontology where not not
everything um
is expressible on this on this type data
data contract level, uh we will store it
um
as metadata or uh um auxiliary
information and then we will be able to
roll it back.
And then thirdly, the most important
thing perhaps um
for our users, for the service designers
for instance, we will we are planning to
uh provide rich um
user and uh user interfaces for for um
software developers where they can come
and say um I need to create this um
sensor health API, right? And give me a
first payload draft for a payload for
for um
for uh sensor health based on bricks and
seas uh source array.
Um
so that in the end it's easier it
becomes easier to create uh such an API
which we then can expose to our
customers and they only they don't need
to deal with any
of these semantic nitty-gritty details.
They only build So, here you can use uh
any any software developer who can build
REST APIs can use these or use rest
APIs, can can
base um his work on these without having
to know whether it's OPC UA in the in
the
in the base or not, right? So, it's
it's somehow protecting people from the
level of details they don't need to
know, right? Or the the level of
verbosity that they don't need to know.
Yeah. So, this is the very first target
picture. We are
very at the infancy of this endeavor and
um
it's a very good opportunity for us also
to be able to present this here because
we are also open for suggestion for
solutions from
from the community.
Mhm.
That's all for my part.
>> [applause]
>> Thank you, Veronica. Are there any
questions?
Um
Oh, we have a mic. Um my name's Alister
Green. Um I spent too much of my life
trying to do this in a different
environment, which was investment
banking.
Um but very similar kinds of problems, I
think. I have a direct question and then
a comment.
Um
is the neutral model repository an
attempt to create a canonical data model
that hides all of the details of all
those underlying ones? No, it's a
canonical syntax, you can say.
>> Canonical syntax, that's all. Okay.
Nothing else. I I have I have a second
direct question, which is how much of
this is driven by
exchange of data or integration of data
and how much of it is driven by just the
desire to be able to understand the data
that you have? No, it's actually all
mostly driven by the need of exchanging
data.
>> Right. Okay.
So um
leaving aside all the organizational
issues, which I'm sure are many and
various um
our experience was and I worked on a
system where we ended up integrating
about 40 systems both intraday data
messaging and and you know uh
bulk data set exchanges. With two
things. First of all,
we could never get
anything to work unless we used central
experts to do the data modeling. You
could never federate the data modeling.
It just doesn't work.
>> Mhm.
And secondly, you need to put technology
in place so that people can actually
query out the data that they want
>> Mhm. from the data that's being
produced. I don't know whether those
match your experiences, but um those
would be two key things. Which this is
completely agnostic of
you know, the technology used for
understanding how to record models and
so forth. Anyway, some
comments. Mhm. Um if I just may reply,
um obviously here our domain experts are
uh heavily involved, right? No no no
none of these um
domain models are created without domain
expert, right? Um the whole point is to
make
once the
they do this and make it available
reusable to others. So that because this
is so costly to have domain experts sit
and and
be in this uh data structure with it's
it is not their own or the syntax which
is not their own, right? Um
so that we can reuse it for our service
designers without them having to go to
the domain expert again because they
what they don't really like is to have
to understand the domain, right? Our
software developers, they like
just
they like when decisions have been made,
right? So um this is the whole point.
Yes, I guess I should clarify. What I
meant was not that you can do this
without domain expertise, but that to
produce any kind of layer that will
allow production and consumption to be
shared, you need to get central people
involved a central team involved in
order to make it to glue it together, to
>> observe the interior to technical
standards that are involved in doing
this. And that way you can extract stuff
from the domain experts, but the domain
experts on their own will not do it.
They will not produce it. So.
There was a second comment, but I
forgotten what you said.
>> [laughter]
>> It was about the ability to
query
>> Yeah, uh-huh. the data that you actually
want if there is some kind of canonical
representation. This is not about
instant data, it's only about the the
schema as well. So, I don't I'm not sure
if you
if this is what you were thinking of.
>> so imagine that
imagine that you have a uh you know,
some some level of commonality of data
model and you can describe the
information. It's got some relationship,
as you said, to actually wanting to
build interfaces to exchange data. And
my point is
you can't produce data for everybody.
You need to be able to find a way of the
consumers being able to select out what
they want, and that will make it work,
right? You produce it once, and you
consume it in many different ways.
Exactly.
What's my other question?
I thought
Let's try.
Um it was kind of related to what
Alister said about a central team. Um
and I wanted to understand
if you went about doing that, and how
you went about doing that, because I
think there've been a few sessions where
I've heard people talking about buying
at the C-suite level.
But unless you actually get buy-in
not at the general level, but at the
soldiers level, you're not going to
succeed. So, I'm interested on comments
on how you did that, and indeed even
from Alister if he's had experience
there as well.
This is a pre-development project but
then the intention is that this is will
be taken over by our so-called
foundational services which do offer a
whole range of basic services to to our
business units when they develop
software. So there's an organization
happy home for it already but we we
don't have the
technical details and so we don't really
know how this team needs to be set up
which kind of skills we need.
Time for one more question?
I was curious you'd mentioned about data
contracts. Are you reusing is there any
kind of
open standards for the data contracts or
have you been prototyping this
within the company?
This neutral model repository this is
our own yeah. This is somehow slightly
related to UML it stands a little bit
between UML and asset administration so
very industry specific
>> [clears throat]
>> but the problem is we have
this forest of syntaxes right? We have
software developers who use link right?
Others are deeply into UML so we needed
to standardize on the on the syntax
level first
>> [clears throat]
>> but this is not an open standard it's
internal only.
All ready.
Thank you very much Veronica wonderful.
>> [applause]